hello I'm Gavin damn we are the slow mo
guys yeah I was in the Army for about
seven years yeah you were dan which
means that I've got a lot of experience
with firing different types of guns yeah
and just before we did the super slow
show we fired possibly the fattest kind
there is big 50 Cal rifle we shot the
mirror right in the face we did within
the rounds we're about this big yeah I
got a headache from firing it due to
many times well you clearly read the
title you know this video is the
complete opposite you have a giveaway
this is a tiny little pin fire gun which
technically isn't a firearm because it's
not rimfire has pin fire sake ring on it
oh you can't miss a key ring you can
wear as a necklace
wow so the 50 Cal was twelve point seven
mil I think okay and that's two mil yeah
which is a hefty difference it's we
there's like 20 rounds in here it's a
tiny little bulb most bullets are bigger
than this you know what we're not doing
a very good size comparison we don't
have a standard procedure American
quarter there you go oh nice one Dorji
wash that's crazy isn't it
I've got sweaty hands so this is gonna
be so hard to do Oh slipped in no safety
but I'm not gonna cook it yet I'm just
gonna put it there that's ready to fire
now you hit that was anything else it
just blow it away I reckon a middle a
middle a yeah okay I'm a bit nervous
because I've never missed from this bar
before perfect mix but will you think
about it when you scale it up it's
further it's like a 25 meters shot yeah
oh it's a hit
you got it I got it Oh makes it dense as
well
are you complaining about me missing
look at this right look at the sheen on
my fingers yeah I have to pull this back
and then after like fire this with my
nail and my sweaty palms it's like
slipping all over the place it's a
wonder I can even fire the damn thing I
mean it's quite powerful if I hit it at
such a low center of gravity and it's
still not the target over cuz that's a
ball okay so let's go frame by frame see
if we need to get faster gum yeah in
that tiny little round it's like oh
there it is this street to the front of
all those sparks there I saw it it was
in the middle of the smoke when it came
up oh wow there's still a street at 12
and a thousand cooks you should have to
crack the barrel like this and then in
there in the end is our spent round so
we've got to get our push rod here shove
it in and it should just push out the
old round it there we go that's the push
rod there you see it's got all like
black carbon around it because it's been
fired and it doesn't have a bullet on it
there whereas these ones let's just open
our little magazine up these ones are
clean and they have little ball bullets
on the end you can see the difference
there I really want one now it's like a
little necklace like a keyring that'd be
so cool yeah someone walks up to you
guys a mate do you carry yeah I've got
an open carry license actually I've gone
all the way over here because I don't
want to get sticky on the cameras
it came out the other side yeah I'm not
getting shot by that thing if we're not
oh that's the entrance there right
through the hole in the e now sy was
aiming for obviously yeah I looked over
and it was just it was spewing out of
both sides it was right this is what I
saw okay I was here just like fire come
on like after a minute fired and I was
surprised that it fired and then because
I had my eyes open all I saw is this
this I saw in slow motion I swear just
strawberries coming straight in my face
I don't even think it hit the table it
just went straight into my eyes and what
is it everything I was just like I mean
straight to me perfect I think it's the
only gun that's actually comical
it's funny how small it is and it even
made a cheeky little exit there just
tore through I've never seen such a
small hole so you would assume that this
is the exit wound but if you push it
together you can actually see that
that's where it went in and it's come
out of here
[Applause]
when the palette comes out the other
side it doesn't split immediately
essentially a few frames where it's just
a hole that's because this is
pressurized so as soon as it like gets
weakened it just goes oh what are you
about to do this to him is gigantic you
know artillery yeah it's like an
artillery cannon or something Oh where'd
he go he just vanished
[Music]
[Laughter]
at this speed when I rocket backwards
and forwards you can actually see the
momentum travel through his body like
he's a full-sized human you can see
where it's hit there and it's like
knocked his arm off he's got an arm off
I'm sorry pal so this bloke has survived
a Lego plane crash yeah and now you blew
his arm off I feel sorry for him now
you've made me feel guilty about it
there's no need for that these earphones
are still on as well his muscles not
protected actually saved his head so
found his hat it's got a huge dent in it
right in the forehead middle part to
scale that's probably about a mile this
hat flew this is an execution my finger
[Music]
because this is so small I want to get a
shot on a macro lens this is a canon
macro lens and this is a PL mount so we
have to do a little bit of open-heart
surgery on the Phantom here first I
should take this lens off
you tilt it down a little bit sort of
lessens the chance that anything will
fall onto the sensor cannon now
Oh stick a shim in there I like how you
are individually tightening the screws a
little bit but it's a circle you can't
get away with just tightening one that
fun yeah if you put one all the way in
then there's no way it's gonna work so
now this phantom fits canon lenses girl
look at the end of that that weird why
me I like you ah we're gonna use the
clamp just to make sure that because the
macro is such a fine little focus and
I've got such fat fingers anytime I fire
it it inevitably moves millimeters left
and right yeah but because we're macro
that means that that's a whole world out
of focus yeah so we're gonna have to use
a clamp here to make sure it just
doesn't move and I'll just fire it oh my
word
makes it look huge oh look at this it
looks so big and heavy it's like it
looks like a huge piece of machinery and
just the fact the legs sink into the
grass was throwing the whole thing that
focus I was him to hold it
I saw you really space racing your thumb
against this I was doing this I was like
I was controlling the whole thing by
extending my finger against the table
yeah
so this will be a macro shot right of
the barrel sorry
it's so quick you don't see anything do
you see anything just for size
comparison in that man crush that I want
to see what the coin looks like next to
the barrel go for it
a good visual comparison there that is
really cool
nice idea I like how the foresight is
out of focus but the side of the barrel
isn't that must be like a millimeter
yeah a quarter is fatter than the
distance between the foresight and the
edge of the barrel which is like about a
millimeter probably so 1 mil out and
you've completely lost focus is it weird
that I had as much fun firing this
little thing as I did the 50 Cal just in
a different way I prefer this because of
course you do rattle my head yeah to be
fair I have a headache after buying this
yeah that's really little fun I might
though on the macro shots take all the
sounds from the 50 Cal and put just
enjoyed the whole of making that video
that's nice and fun it wasn't easy
um start from the macro that was an
idler surprisingly powerful though yeah
have to be careful with these things
they're not to be messed around with
really well I mean we saw what it did to
the can it has exit wing exactly you
don't want that in your eye or your any
skin no so just point it away at all
times you're wearing that safety gloves
yeah good stuff so my trigger discipline
was solid today hopefully you enjoyed
that video feel free to follow us on
Instagram subscribe to our YouTube
channel that's this one we've also got
the other one behind the scenes and all
that slow mo guys too you can bunk that
a sub as well if you want it's just more
us tragically just it's more of us
blokes we'll see you in the next video